la douleur normalement vous devez à peu
près savoir ce que c'est surtout si vous
avez regardé ma première vidéo sur le
sujet mais il y a un type de douleur
bien particulier qui est moins connu que
les autres et c'est embêtant parce qu'on
a vraiment intérêt à savoir les repérer
pour pouvoir se soigner si ça nous
arrive c'est douleur c'est les douleurs
neuropathiques je vous explique ça tout
de suite
donc il y a pas si longtemps on parlait
de la douleur dans la première vidéo de
ma série sur le sujet pour poser les
bases si vous voulez si c'est pas fait
je vous conseille d'aller la regarder
dans cette vidéo je vous disais qu'il y
a plusieurs types de douleurs il n'y a
pas qu'une seule sorte de douleur et
aujourd'hui je vous propose de parler un
peu plus en détail de l'une d'entre
elles parce que vous allez voir c'est
une forme de douleur qu'on connaît mal
et pourtant on devrait cette douleur
c'est ce qu'on appelle la douleur
neuropathique oui alors je sais vous
aviez deviné parce que c'est dans le
titre et j'en ai littéralement déjà
parlé dans l'intro bon mais vous vous
souvenez la douleur classique celle
qu'on ressent quand on prend un coup
quand on se pique qu'on se coupe qu'on
se brûle etc c'est la douleur
nociceptive et donc la douleur
neuropathique ou plutôt les douleurs
neuropathiques parce que vous allez voir
qu'il y en a plusieurs c'est celle qu'on
ressent quand notre système nerveux est
touché et comme notre système nerveux il
est divisé en deux parties on a deux
sortes de douleurs neuropathiques les
douleurs neuropathiques centrales quand
c'est le système nerveux central c'est à
dire le cerveau ou la moelle épinière
qui est atteint et les douleurs
neuropathiques périphériques quand c'est
le système nerveux périphérique
c'est-à-dire les nerfs qui est touché
oui on a été sympa sur les moyens
mnémotechniques les douleurs
neuropathiques centrales c'est pas les
plus fréquentes mais on va quand même en
parler dans la majorité des cas elles
sont causées par une lésion de la moelle
épinière après un traumatisme au niveau
de la colonne vertébrale dans ces cas-là
les douleurs elles apparaissent soit
au-dessus soit en dessous de la blessure
elles peuvent aussi apparaître après un
accident vasculaire cérébral un AVC vous
souvenez un vaisseau qui pète ou qui se
bouche dans le cerveau on en avait parlé
dans une autre vidéo la les douleurs
elle se situe plutôt dans un membre du
côté opposé de la zone du cerveau qui a
été touchée oui parce que c'est la
partie droite de notre cerveau qui
contrôle le côté gauche de notre corps
et la partie gauche qui contrôle le côté
droit
on aime bien faire compliqué et puis il
y a toutes les autres maladies qui
peuvent toucher le système nerveux
centrale comme la sclérose en plaques la
maladie de Parkinson les tumeurs
cérébrales etc donc ça c'est pour les
douleurs neuropathiques centrales vous
avez vu la plupart du temps elles
accompagnent des problèmes de santé
relativement importants donc en général
on est au courant mais les douleurs
neuropathiques les plus fréquentes c'est
les douleurs neuropathiques
périphériques et celle-là c'est moins
facile de les identifier à l'origine des
douleurs neuropathiques périphériques il
y a quelque chose qui endommage les
nerfs une opération chirurgicale par
exemple je sais pas si vous vous
souvenez on avait parlé de la douleur du
membre fantôme vous savez les gens qui
ont mal dans un membre alors qu'il a été
amputé et bah c'est une forme très
particulière de douleur neuropathiques
périphériques mais il y en a aussi après
des opérations plus classiques comme la
pose d'une prothèse de genou par exemple
vous connaissez peut-être pas mais c'est
classique comme opération ça peut aussi
être causé par un virus comme l'herpès
par exemple dans le cas d'une maladie
qui s'appelle le zona et qui est causé
par la réactivation du virus de la
varicelle dans notre corps qui se met à
attaquer nos nerfs oui la varicelle
c'est une forme d'herpès je suis désolé
de piétiner votre enfance comme ça
les nerfs ils peuvent aussi être abimés
par des maladies comme le diabète ou
l'endométriose mais aussi par des
médicaments comme certaines
chimiothérapies bref vous avez compris
il y a plein de causes différentes
possibilités bon mais donc ces douleurs
à quoi ressemble bah oui parce que si on
veut les reconnaître c'est quand même
super important de le savoir il faut
connaître son ennemi pour mieux le
combattre oui c'est un peu belliqueux et
c'est pas de moi mais j'aimais bien le
côté punchline voilà en fait il y a une
partie de notre système nerveux
périphérique qui s'appelle le système
nerveux somatique le système nerveux
somatique il a un certain nombre de
rôles et il y en a un qui va nous
intéresser tout particulièrement il est
chargé de transmettre les sensations au
cerveau les sensations douloureuses mais
aussi le show le froid et tout ce qui se
rapporte à la peau et au toucher et
c'est cette partie du système nerveux
quand elle est touchée qui donne
naissance aux douleurs neuropathiques
périphériques du coup concrètement ça
donne des sensations douloureuses de
froid ou de chaud comme des brûlures ça
peut aussi ressembler à des décharges
électriques ou des coûts très aigus
comme nous des coups de poignard et ça
s'accompagne de tout un tas de
sensations liées au toucher qui peuvent
aller des démangeaisons aux
fourmillements aux engourdissements en
passant par une hypersensibilité ou à
l'inverse une insensibilité de certaines
zones ou des extrémités les extrémités
c'est les doigts par exemple ou les
orteils on voit bien le rôle du système
nerveux somatique là avec ces espèces de
forme hybride qui mélange douleur et
sensation gênantes voilà donc c'est ça
des douleurs neuropathiques alors si
vous en avez une fois ou deux comme ça
et puis après on en parle plus ça va ça
peut arriver mais si ça vous arrive
régulièrement et surtout si ça dure plus
de trois mois bah il faut aller voir
votre médecin et oui parce que vous vous
souvenez ce que je disais dans ma vidéo
précédente je suis sûr qu'un jour ou
l'autre quelqu'un vous a déjà dit non
mais ça va c'est normal d'avoir mal
alors soyons clairs non c'est pas normal
bah évidemment c'est aussi valable pour
les douleurs neuropathiques donc il faut
pas attendre que ça passe vous voulez
une bonne raison de le faire sans
attendre on sait avec certitude qu'à
terme les douleurs neuropathiques elles
peuvent entraîner de l'anxiété voire une
dépression et vu qu'on sait aussi que
l'anxiété et la dépression c'est deux
facteurs qui aggravent les douleurs vous
pas envie de rentrer dans ce cercle
vicieux bon allez vous voulez encore
trois bonnes raisons ça provoque aussi
des troubles du sommeil de l'appétit et
de la libido c'est non ça fait beaucoup
là non vous avez compris à terme ça
dégrade tous les aspects de la vie
personnelle professionnelle social etc
ouais parce que tout ça ça a aussi des
répercussions sur votre moral sur votre
humeur sur votre capacité à mener à bien
vos activités habituelles donc pas ouf
et si vous voulez encore d'autres bonnes
raisons d'ailleurs il y en a autant
qu'il y a de trucs qui causent ces
fameuses douleurs autant de cause qu'il
faut traiter pour éviter d'avoir mal
bien sûr mais aussi pour éviter que ça
s'aggrave donc il faut aller chez son
médecin parce que les douleurs
neuropathiques ça soigne mais pour ça il
faut les avoir identifiés ok mais
comment ça soigne bah vous doutez bien
que vu que c'est quelque chose de
complexe il y a pas de pilule miracle
mais il y a des solutions faut en parler
votre médecin donc le traitement il se
fait sur plusieurs plans un plan
purement physique avec de la kiné voire
de l'ergothérapie un plan psychologique
on a vu les répercussions que les
douleurs ont à ce niveau évidemment il
faut s'en occuper des médicaments bien
sûr liberté à la cause des douleurs mais
aussi des antalgiques c'est-à-dire des
antidouleurs parfois des antidépresseurs
voire des médicaments contre l'épilepsie
parce qu'on a remarqué qu'il pouvait
marcher dans ces cas-là des
anesthétiques locaux à appliquer
directement sur la peau au niveau de la
zone qui fait mal etc et puis il y a
tout un tas d'autres possibilités qui
peuvent aller de la chirurgie si c'est
nécessaire à ce qu'on appelle la
neuropodulation ah je sens que vous êtes
titillé avec mon gros mot compliqué vous
avez raison c'est hyper intéressant la
neuromodulation ça consiste à stimuler
la moelle épinière et les nerfs avec un
boîtier implanté qui envoie des petites
impulsions électriques pour parasiter la
transmission du message douloureux au
cerveau c'est pour faire diversion un
peu si vous voulez attention derrière
vous en tout cas il y a des solutions il
y a plein de solutions il y a des gens
dont c'est le métier donc si vous devez
retenir un seul truc ça serait si vous
avez un doute parlez-en à votre médecin
n'hésitez pas à lui demander qui vous
envoie dans un centre spécialisé si
besoin un centre de lutte contre la
douleur avant de vous laisser juste un
chiffre les douleurs neuropathiques
chroniques ça touche 4 millions de
personnes en France donc si vous êtes
concerné ou si vous avez un doute je
vous mets des liens qui vont vous être
utile dans la description de cette vidéo
et notamment la carte des structures
spécialisées dans la prise en charge de
la douleur pour que vous puissiez en
trouver une près de chez vous voilà DTC
c'est fini pour aujourd'hui on se
retrouve très vite pour de nouvelles
vidéos d'ici là prenez soin de vous et
prenez soin des autres mettez-vous bien
et surtout portez-vous bien
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]